if you're going to spend all the time to
write a script and try to build a career
you might as well focus on something
that has like a higher probability of
success
what is a gold mine genre it's a phrase
I'm made of so it's not like a it's not
like an industry term but it's um uh
it's I I call them gold mines because
they are just core genres that through
good times and bad times
have been and as far as I can possibly
see will always be in need year on year
in the entertainment industry so it's
just basic buckets of genres that for
whatever reason you know for the past
several hundred years whether in book
form stage play and now movies and TV
shows they just hit a certain audience
that's large enough to keep momentum
moving so if those genres if if they're
seen by a Distribution Company a
production company a studio
they always sort of take them a little
bit more seriously than something that
doesn't fit easily into that uh and and
budget is sort of you know doesn't
really apply it's they can be extremely
low budget they can be extremely big
budget but it's more just what kind of
film is it is it a female driven
Thriller is it a Christmas uh romance uh
is it something along those those
categories that just fits perfectly with
what the industry needs year on year how
many gold mine genres are there uh I I
say six
um
I mean you can you can dive a little bit
deeper than that but I mean it really
kind of fits into six there's Christmas
uh there is uh female driven Thriller
there is tween girl
uh there's sort of
I I call it like the Aging male action
hero film uh there's creature features
and then there are
um I'd call it like
boy uh family safe but boy driven
adventure story so that'd be like your
treasure Hunters uh kind of uh Spy Kids
kind of thing
um you know creature features those are
kind of self-evident and those range
from like Sharknado to like very high
budgeted Hollywood films uh your aging
male action uh hero film on the extreme
low budget these are movies that are
shot like for less than a million and a
half or two million dollars but they
have like Jean-Claude Van Damme or Dolph
Lundgren for like one day on set and
they're like The Mastermind boss at a
desk and they edit it so it appears you
know scattered throughout the film but
the key thing is that they get to be on
the poster
um Christmas movies they're self-evident
if you can throw in a dog that's great
the tween girl films
um
I really like them when they have a
horse in them or if they have some kind
of animal a part of it those also work
with Christmas I think Christmas dog
movies work well uh Christmas and a
horse that absolutely fits the season if
you have a nice snowy background and all
um and then uh yeah it's it's they just
work consistently and you'll see them
like once you kind of categorize it like
that you'll see them every year
um uh big Studio films down to like
microscopic microscopic budgetedly
titles like you'll see them those are
the ones that just Hollywood
consistently needs
um you see lots of comedies you see lots
of horror uh that stuff is usually
developed the other way around which
means that um a studio is trying to
promote a big comedy Talent
and The Comedy Central worked like this
for a long time so if you have somebody
like an Amy Schumer you know they start
they identified her and they sort of
started they kind of dabbled a bit by
testing with like well let's do some
one-hour specials and see how that does
okay the audience is there it works
let's maybe put them in a movie or
something and you see that with a lot of
Comedy Talent it follows that kind of
pattern so they're not like it's not
like somebody wrote the script and then
uh the studio Executives just went wow
this is great let's get this talent to
put it's the opposite way around they're
trying to build a giant brand around a
talent and promote that talent in their
career and horror is very different
horror is uh such a Fickle genre it's um
you need to nail it and it's it's the
audience is so specific with horror and
the attributes that that
um will land a horror film are very
different than other genres like who the
director is is is critical in horror uh
and sometimes so it kind of comes since
the the director or some key aspect of
the genre is actually what keeps the
audience engaged or interested uh some
of the creative ideas actually have to
come from that Source out and then it
Maps out so those are I think those are
just really hard ones to enter into and
then just like standard issue dramas
like
they're just boring they they require so
much talent to uh sell it and that
Talent is so expensive it just makes it
really complicated
when you're talking about some of the
movies that most screenwriters would be
sort of hired for it would be like just
sort of one protagonist correct yeah
it's it's
um
you got to think of it like barriers to
entry uh you know not to use too much
like business jargon in this kind of
setting but I mean I think screenwriters
if you're if you're going to be starting
a career you need to think about it as a
career in an industry
um and I think that the easiest point of
entry is yeah focusing on the one
protagonist story you can have your B
plot you should but um it's really got
to follow that one protagonist on his or
her journey usually her it's it's I
think I think there's a much larger
female audience in general or a much
larger need of content for female
audiences so I think having a
protagonist be female is is pretty
critical in whatever genre you focus on
take the movie with Rob Lowe the dog
movie that's done really well on Netflix
but there's also the Channing Tatum one
that's it's a dog movie too it's a it's
a great vehicle yeah but women like
uh
they are they it is it is an attractive
story to have
um a guy with a dog uh that combo can
actually be quite appealing they've done
a lot of dating studies on this
apparently sure sure absolutely what
about a guy with a cat this is quite it
doesn't quite nail it the same way I
mean what if it's an exotic cat okay
yeah and then we've I think I've
definitely seen the cat film Christmas
movie let's say I've seen like the cat
film tried a few times it just doesn't
land it unless the cat because cats have
such a unique character you know why is
it important for writers to understand
these genres it's
it's important just to step back and
understand how the industry works
uh and since these are the genres that
are just consistently in need
um focusing a lot of attention on theirs
is I think pretty critical like it's
it's
if you're gonna spend all the time to
write a script and try to build a career
you might as well focus on something
that has like a higher probability of
success than something that has a lot
more barriers of you know restriction
against you uh so if you're just
focusing on these genres understanding
and being realistic that like hey this
is what real people want to watch
and choosing to write that just makes a
little bit more logical sense in terms
of like opening your doors of
opportunity
and one shouldn't think that these
genres
are you know just overly cliched or or
uh not important enough it's it's
there's so many stories you can tell
within them and it's it's you can dive
really deep into character and really
convey some amazing ideas even with
these sort of like tried and tested
genres
so I don't think they should be
dismissed I think there's a lot of
really good opportunity for writers in
them and you're talking about working
writers writers that are not on a TV
show that have a career that that make
money that support themselves from their
scripts to churn out these things it's
not just like a a one-off art film that
they're going to win a contest these are
people that you know are building a
career off this yeah yeah and these are
these are definitely career writers who
who like the writers we work with we
work with them consistently and they
churn out scripts uh I mean I don't need
to undercut it but I mean like they can
write fast and they can deliver quickly
and you know they're writing a new
script every month maybe every two
months and they're getting paid on them
and so it's like that is a career they
built that slowly it took time to build
but they got to a point where they said
like look I can deliver tween girl
movies like really really well I can
write them very fast I can write them in
in really strong detail I can convey
some very solid uh wonderful ideas
within them I mean think about what you
can do with that you can explore so many
ideas about complications and
Adolescence stress you feel with
adolescence you can dive into mental
health issues you can dive into body
positivity you can dive into so many
facets all within like one cliched idea
and if you're going to be writing these
deep uh uh experiences or if you're
going to be writing meaningful stories
and you just put it inside the bright
shiny box of a gold mine genre like
you're gonna get noticed I'm not saying
you're gonna get the deal it's like like
you might as well do the thing that's
going to open more doors of opportunity
for you so if you do some deep
overwhelming coming-of-age story uh
that's just gonna like disappear in
somebody's inbox or if you say it's a
tween girl film and it follows it's
about so and so doing XYZ and you know
it talks about these themes because it's
a tween girl film it's going to get
opened at least by more people
where would you put Wednesday Adams
that's complicated because it is a piece
of known IP it's it's a derivative of
something we've known through a lot of
different variations the original Show
the movie variations in the 90s they've
had a couple of animated versions of it
so there already comes a bit of like a
cult identity with it so that falls into
what we talked about before in terms of
verifiable audience there's always been
a subgroup of people that respond well
to the sort of quirky dark comedies or
just films that dive deep into that uh
and then they just I guess it's maybe a
reboot slash spin-off because you're
focused on her it's sort of a weird
hybrid and Netflix gets to do this
because they have so much money
um they can really take interesting
chances but it's talent-led meaning the
creative Talent LED somebody very high
up in in some big agencies basically
came to them with the concept and
because it's a known piece of Ip you've
got a really good recipe for something
there to play with
but it is a tween girl film at the end
of the day it's following her and going
through a journey so